a new era is underway in Saudi Arabia
this morning have you heard newly
empowered women got behind the wheel
overnight as the world's last ban on
female drivers ended it was an emotional
moment for many women who have fought
nearly three decades for this privilege
a lot of us take it for granted Holly
Williams is in the capital Riyadh where
women's rights campaigners face more
challenges ahead Holly good morning to
you good morning a group of brave Saudi
women protested for 28 years
demanding the right to drive and risking
arrest but they didn't get anywhere
until Saudi Arabia's Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman began shaking up
this Islamic Kingdom with a series of
reforms allowing cinemas music concerts
and women to finally get in the driver's
seat one short drive for college student
Han and al-husayn one huge leap forward
for Saudi Arabia she's one of hundreds
of Saudi women who now have their
license I like being independent I don't
like to count on someone else to do my
stuff for me the Saudi government has
set up high-tech all-female driving
schools to help others pass their test
women here are now joining the work
force in record numbers and pushing the
limits of their freedom
Hana is a fan of extreme sports who
agreed to show us her drift driving
skills it's like I'm in control of where
I want to go this feeling I love it her
family however prefers that she doesn't
show her face on camera a reminder that
this remains a deeply conservative
country where women still need a male
relatives permission to travel overseas
or get married to tempt more women to
drive they've set up these simulators
outside of busy shopping mall but
changing old attitudes in Saudi Arabia
won't be easy in recent weeks the Saudi
government arrested several women's
rights campaigners who pushed for
greater equality they're accused of
conspiring against the authorities
Fionna
Hana is the Danica Patrick of Saudi
Arabia Holly Williams in Saudi Arabia
thank you for that so glad that has
happened when Saudi clerics said that he
was worried about women driving because
it would push their pelvic forward when
they were driving and affect their
ovaries yeah how do you problem with
your ovaries ovaries are just fine yes
fine